♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE MOST REMARKABLE
FACT ABOUT THE DECLINE OF MEN IN
AMERICA IS MOST LEADERS
PRETENDING IT'S NOT HAPPENING AT
ALL.
THE PATRIARCHY IS THRIVING THEY
TELL US, MEN ARE IN CHARGE AND
THEY SUCCEED EQUAL TO WOMEN.
THIS IS WRONG AND WE MUST
RECTIFY IT.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE.
IT ALSO HAPPENS TO BE THE CORE
ASSUMPTIONS OF SECOND WAVE
FEMINISM WHICH BECAME POPULAR 40
YEARS AGO WHEN THE BABY BOOM
LEADERS WERE BECOMING OF AGE.
NONE OF THOSE ASSUMPTIONS ARE
TRUE TODAY.
AMERICA HAS CHANGED COMPLETELY.
THE PATRIARCHY IS GONE, WOMEN
ARE WINNING, MEN ARE FAILING.
MEN IN AMERICA ARE NOW FAR MORE
LIKELY TO DIE OF A DRUG
OVERDOSE, DROP OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE BECAUSE OF AN
ADDICTION, COMMIT A FELONY, AND
GO TO PRISON.
THEY FAIL IN SCHOOL MUCH MORE
OFTEN THAN WOMEN DO.
THEY KILL THEMSELVES AT MANY
TIMES THE RATE, OVERALL THEY
DIED EIGHT YEARS YOUNGER.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE NOT
SPECULATIVE, THEY ARE HARD DATA
GATHERED OVER DECADES OF
NONPARTISAN RESEARCHERS.
YOU HAVE TO IGNORE A HUGE AMOUNT
OF SETTLED SCIENCE OR TO REPEAT
THE PIETIES OF 1970s ERA
FEMINISM AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
ARE LEADERS INTENDED TO DO.
IN MARCH OF 2009, ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY AFTER ARRIVING IN
WASHINGTON, BARACK OBAMA GREETED
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNCIL ON WOMEN
AND GIRLS.
HE TAPS A DIVISOR TO RUN IT.
THE SAME EDUCATION AND CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES AS OUR SONS, OBAMA
SAID IN HIS ANNOUNCEMENT, THAT
AFFECTS OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
FUTURE AS A NATION.
AT THE VERY MOMENT, OBAMA WAS
LAMENTING THE LACK OF
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WOMEN, MORE GIRLS THAN BOYS WERE
GRADUALLY FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND
FAR MORE FROM COLLEGE.
62% OF WOMEN ARE OWNING
ASSOCIATES DEGREES, 60% OF
MASTERS DEGREES, AND 52% OF
DOCTORATES.
THAT GAP IS EVEN WIDER AND
NONWHITE NEIGHBORHOODS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN 2007 AMONG BLACK
AND HISPANIC GRADUATES OF PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN BOSTON, FOR EVERY 100
BLACK MEN WHO HAD A COLLEGE
DEGREE, THERE WERE 230 BLACK
WOMEN WHO GOT ONE.
FOR EVERY 100 HISPANIC MEN WHO
GOT A COLLEGE DEGREE, THERE WERE
211 HISPANIC WOMEN WHO GOT ONE.
THE 70% OF ALL MASTERS DEGREES
AWARDED TO BLACK STUDENTS
NATIONALLY WENT TO BLACK WOMEN,
JUST 30% WENT TO BLACK MEN.
THE REASONS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION NEVER EXPLAINED,
THOUGH SCHOOL PERFORMANCE OF
BLACK AND HISPANIC GIRLS WAS
DEEMED A HIGHER PRIORITY THAN
BOYS.
UNDER OBAMA, THE WHITE HOUSE
SOLICITED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FROM CORPORATIONS TO ENCOURAGE
FEMALE ACHIEVEMENT AND HIGHER
EDUCATION.
AT THE TIME THIS WAS HAPPENING,
ONE STUDY SHOWED THAT THERE WAS
ALREADY AT LEAST FOUR TIMES AS
MANY PRIVATELY FUNDED COLLEGE
SCHOLARSHIPS AVAILABLE FOR GIRLS
AS FOR BOYS, FOUR TIMES.
THE ADMINISTRATION OF HER
KNOWLEDGE THE INSTEAD, IT SOUGHT
NEW WAYS TO CLOSE A GENDER GAP
THAT NO LONGER EXISTS.
ONE IDEA WAS "BREAKING DOWN
GENDER STEREOTYPES AND TOYS."
TO THAT END, THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESSURED MANUFACTURERS,
RETAILERS, AND MEDIA OUTLETS TO
ELIMINATE GENDER DISTINCTION AND
CHILDREN'S TOYS.
THIS WOULD ALLOW KIDS TO
EXPLORE, LEARN, AND DREAM
WITHOUT LIMITS.
WHILE EDUCATORS OF ALL LEVELS
TOOK THIS IDEA SERIOUSLY.
IN 2015, ONE KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER IN WASHINGTON STATE
BANNED HER MALE STUDENTS FROM
PLAYING WITH LEGOS.
A FITTING TOGETHER PLASTIC
BLOCKS HAS BEEN FOUND BY
RESEARCHERS TO HELP CHILDREN
DEVELOP IMPORTANT COGNITIVE
SKILLS.
BOYS HAVE ENOUGH ADVANTAGES, THE
TEACHER EXPLAINED.
SHE INTENTIONALLY PREVENTED THEM
FROM LEARNING.
HER GIRLS THRIVE WHEN BOYS FAIL.
THIS IS THE UNDERLYING
ASSUMPTION OF MUCH OF AMERICA'S
GENDER POLICY AND EDUCATION.
THERE IS NO CREDIBLE RESEARCH TO
SUGGEST THAT IS TRUE.
IT IS PURELY AN IDEOLOGICAL
BELIEF AND YET THAT ASSUMPTION
IS PERVASIVE, ESPECIALLY ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THAT'S IRONIC BECAUSE THERE ARE
MORE THAN 2 MILLION MORE WOMEN
THAN MEN ENROLLED IN COLLEGE
THIS YEAR.
ON MOST CAMPUSES, MEN ARE A
DISTINCT MINORITY.
AT A UNIVERSITY IN PITTSBURGH,
WOMEN ARE A NUMBER MEN BY MORE
THAN 6-1.
ALMOST EVERY CAMPUS HAS A
WOMEN'S STUDIES DEPARTMENT.
MANY OF THEM, THE STATED GOAL IS
TO FIGHT EXPRESSIONS OF
MASCULINITY AND DISEMPOWER MEN.
AT OHIO STATE OHIO STATE, A
FORCE IS UNDERWAY THIS SPRING
CALLED BE A MAN COME OUT
MASCULINITY'S RACE, AND NATION.
THE SYLLABUS FOR THAT COURSE
EXPLICIT MASCULINITY IS USED TO
JUSTIFY CERTAIN KINDS OF
VIOLENCE BY MEN.
ON THE FIRST DAY OF CLASS,
STUDENTS WERE REQUIRED TO
CONSULT A MALE PRIVILEGE
CHECKLIST.
AT DUKE UNIVERSITY AND
NORTH CAROLINA, A NINE WEEK
WORKSHOP MEANT TO DEVISE WAYS TO
UNDERMINE "MASCULINITY AND
MALENESS" AS WELL TO DESTABILIZE
SPACES WITH PRIVILEGE, MEETING
MEN.
SIMILAR PROJECTS HAVE SPRUNG UP
COLLEGES OVER THE COUNTRY.
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CREDIT
SOMETHING CALLED THE HEALTHY
MASCULINITY CAMPUS ATHLETICS
PROJECT.
THAT OBJECTIVE WAS SUMMED UP
THIS WAY "AS A COUNTRY WE NEED
TO DO A BETTER JOB OF ADDRESSING
ISSUES AROUND TOXIC MASCULINITY
MASCULINITY."
LEFT ON ASKED WAS THE MOST BASIC
QUESTION OF ALL, IT IS
MASCULINITY ITSELF REALLY TOXIC
AND WHAT HAPPENS TO BOYS ONLY
IT'S WHY WE UNDERSTOOD THAT
ATTACKING PEOPLE FOR THEIR BASIC
NATURE IS UNHEALTHY AND IT'S
WRONG TO READ A GOVERNMENT
FUNDED PROGRAM DESIGNED TO FIGHT
TOXIC FEMININITY OR TOXIC
HOMOSEXUALITY PROBABLY WOULD NOT
ESCAPE THE SCRUTINY OF CONGRESS
OR THE MEDIA.
AT THE VERY LEAST, THE
SUPPORTERS WOULD HAVE TO EXPLAIN
WHY OUR COUNTRY NEEDS A PROGRAM
LIKE THAT.
YET NOBODY HAS BEEN FORCED TO
EXPLAIN WHY BOYS WHO ARE ALREADY
FAILING NEED TO BE HELD BACK
FURTHER.
SO THEY ARE.
CHRISTINA HOFF SUMMERS IS THE
SHE'S ONE OF THE VERY FIRST
PEOPLE IN AMERICA INTELLECTUAL
LIFE TO NOTICE THIS TREND AND TO
SOUND THE ALARM.
SHE WAS IGNORED, BUT WE'RE
GRATEFUL SHE DID IT ANYWAY.
THANK YOU.
YOU WROTE THIS ORIGINAL PIECE
FROM WHICH THIS WHOLE SERIES
BASICALLY HAS BEEN DERIVED
ALMOST 20 YEARS AGO WHEN YOU
NOTICE TO THE BOYS WERE FALLING
BEHIND.
YET THE ASSUMPTION FOR THE
PEOPLE HAVE NOT CHANGED MUCH.
WHY?
>> THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF
RESISTANCE TO ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF BOYS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF ROMAN'S
GROUPS, NOT ALL OF THEM, BUT
MOST OF THEM CALL IT BACKLASH
AND THEY ARE UNWILLING TO
LISTEN, SO BOYS BECAUSE WE'VE
THROWN THE GENDER SWITCH AND
BOYS ARE ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
THE GENDER GAP.
>> Tucker: THE CORE ASSUMPTION
IS THERE IS SOME ARRANGEMENT
WHERE IF YOU HOLD BACK BOYS,
GIRLS SHOULD AHEAD AND IT'S
GREAT FOR THEM, BUT THAT'S NOT
REALLY THE NATURE OF LIFE.
>> IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL FALLACY.
THERE'S TOO MANY OF THE ACTIVIST
GROUPS THAT THINK THAT THERE IS
A TROPHY AND EITHER VENUS IS
GOING TO WIN OR MARS AND THEIR
MEN AND WOMEN AND BOYS AND GIRLS
ARE IN THIS TOGETHER.
IF BOYS ARE IN TROUBLE, SO ARE
WE ALL.